this episode of the yfiles is brought to
you by the Y files operation podcast
deep Dives and longer stories every
week the story of the human race is a
story of Technology one of our ancestors
created fire and passed that knowledge
along to the Next Generation then the
invention of the wheel then agriculture
a writing system mathematics space
travel within our story Empires rise and
fall and Technology progresses
civilizations are born and die and the
human race continues to innovate all of
our Innovations are built on previous
ones there could be no Aqueduct without
the arch there could be no metal plow
until someone learned how to mine iron
there could be no light bulb no
smartphone and no computer without first
understanding electricity our progress
is linear it's orderly but sometimes an
object is discovered that's completely
out of place and out of time a computer
found on a sunken Roman ship a power
plant PL found in a 100,000 year old
cave an Evidence of nuclear reactor from
over a billion years ago these objects
shouldn't exist but they do their
existence violates the natural order of
human progress so if humans didn't
create these items who
[Music]
did until next time be safe be kind and
know that you are appreciated
sir I'm going to need you to come with
us uh
[Music]
okay hello can anybody hear me I don't
know why I'm here take off the pillow
case we are agents with the cfp
cfp I I don't know what that is I I
never heard of that yeah that's not your
concern uh okay we have been following
your show and we have reason to
hey dude I thought I was going to do the
investigation this time do it then do it
stop sitting there do it all right jeez
we have been following your show and we
have reason to believe that you have far
more information on your topics that
you've been sharing uh what we have been
following your show no no no I I I heard
you I just I I just don't know what that
means we have been following your show
you speak English you your
question is confusing my question is not
confusing yeah it is he's
playing well if you know that I have
more information then you already know
that I what I know that you know just
tell us what we want to know okay what
what what episode are you talking about
what episode are we talking about I
don't know dude you you're the
researcher no you're supposed to know
this what the heck the one that has more
information look guys I have a podcast
that covers all of this the yfiles
operation podcast comes out every week
on Mondays we release the YouTube
episodes and then on Wednesdays we do
deep dives into those stories and then
we cover unredacted topics that are a
little too sensitive for
YouTube makees sense and uh where does
this podcast air you can get it on Apple
Amazon Spotify Pandora anywhere you
listen to podcast this sounds really
convenient actually yeah super smart
okay go unlock his cuffs so can I go me
unlock the Cuffs you have the keys No I
gave you the keys you did not
specifically put them under them you got
the keys
you're the one who sat on the syringe
start telling
everyone that we were Men In Black and
we're way cooler than we are way cooler
than the guys in the movies give me a
little
support wait wait where did he go a damn
it not
again in 1962 an article was published
about an archaeological Expedition that
explored explor the Bayan har mountains
of Tibet in
1937 the team led by archaeologist Chu
discovered 716 Granite discs engraved
with characters that looked like
hieroglyphics each disc was 9 in in
diameter and 1 in thick with a perfect
1-in hole in the center the stones were
dated to more than 12,000 years ago but
they weren't the strangest thing found
at the site not even close the team
discovered Advanced star maps and the
remain of unusual humanoids the beings
were small with thin bodies and large
heads
aliens well it took more than 20 years
of trying but the markings on the discs
were finally translated the discs told
the story of a vessel that traveled to
Earth from outer space the inscriptions
described a crash in the mountains of
Tibet and what happened to the survivors
of the crash I knew it the writing also
gave the beings a name they were called
the dropa
the droper came down from the clouds in
their aircraft our men women and
children hid in the caves 10 times
Before Sunrise when at last we
understood the sign language of the
droper we realized that the newcomers
had peaceful
intentions these findings were published
in 1962 by Professor suum umnu but as
could be expected his peers didn't take
it seriously the story and the stones
resurfaced 6 years later but this time
in Russia scientists discover the
granite used to make the stones
contained extremely high amounts of
cobalt and other heavy metals these
properties would have made the stones
very hard to carve with primitive tools
12,000 years ago the stones were tested
with an oscillograph a device used to
read current and voltage the results
indicated the stones had once been
electrically charged or might have been
electrical conductors after these new
discoveries the stones disappeared again
until they turned up in the bomo museum
in China in 1974 before Austrian
engineer erns Wagner went to the museum
to see the stones although the museum
wouldn't give him any information about
them he was allowed to take photographs
of the stones that same year a book was
published called Sun gods in Exile by
David agamon and that book would prove
everything Sun gods in Exile tells the
story of Oxford Professor Carl Robin
Evans and his 1947 Expedition into the
bayh har mountains there he encountered
living drone where he learned their
language and learned their history from
their religious leader luran la luran la
told him the dropa came from a planet in
the Syria system and they had come to
Earth on an exploratory Mission 12,000
years ago their ship crash landed in the
Himalayas and Stranded the dropa on
Earth forever the book was based on the
Journal of Dr Carl Robin Evans and that
journal had
pictures this is huip Pala and vzla the
rulers of the jopa in 194 47 the journal
describes the dropa as a small race
averaging 42 in height and only 60 lb
they have large heads with large Blue
Eyes in 1994 German scientist Hartwig
house dworf went to the bampo museum in
China and asked to see the stones for
himself well he was told the stones were
destroyed on official orders when house
dorf tried to look further into the drop
a tribe and their Stones the Chinese
government said they had no record of
any stones or a tribe known as the dropa
as far as the Chinese government was
concerned the dropa never
existed in the year 1900 off the coast
of a small Greek island a group of men
were diving for sponges during one dive
at a depth of around 150 ft they found
something very unexpected an ancient
Roman shipwreck the ship was full of
ancient Greek artifacts dating back over
2,000 years coins Pottery statues and
many other items were brought back to
the surface among the wreckage was a
heavily weathered block made of wood and
calcified bronze the block was taken to
the museum with the rest of the
artifacts but it didn't really look like
anything so it was mostly ignored but 2
years later archaeologist Valerio Stace
took a closer look at the unassuming
block it didn't take long for him to
discover there was a lot more to the
block than people realized he could make
out the shape of a large gear GE
embedded in the calcified Stone he
believed it was some sort of ancient
astronomical clock mainstream
archaeologists dismissed the idea as
prisic meaning to Advan for the time
period or the wreckage the ship was
underwater for 2,000 years the type of
Technology needed to build an
astronomical clock just didn't exist yet
in fact Gears of this quality wouldn't
be invented until the 14th century about
1,700 years
later mainstream scientists said the
object must have found its way onto the
ship at a much later time and therefore
wasn't all that special or important so
the object was placed on a shelf in a
dark back room of a museum and that's
where it stayed completely ignored for
50 years but in 1951 Yale Professor
Derek J DOA price was researching
ancient clocks he heard about a
mysterious object discovered off the
coast of a small Greek island called
antia price looked into the artifact but
his findings didn't impress his
colleagues but he would continue
researching the device for the next 23
years then in 1974 with the help of a
nuclear physicist price used xray and
gamma ray Imaging to examine 82 pieces
of the
rock this Imaging revealed an assortment
of bronze Gears of various sizes all
connected to a central crank as the
gears spun they would move hands on the
object's face like the hands of a clock
but this device wasn't designed to tell
you what time it was it was designed to
do much much
more nothing like this instrument is
preserved elsewhere nothing comparable
to it is known from any ancient
scientific text or literary illusion it
is a bit frightening to know that just
before the fall of their great
civilization the ancient Greeks had come
so close to our age not only in their
thought but also in their Scientific
Technology by 2009 scientists had
gathered enough scans and images to
reconstruct what the anti mechanism had
looked like it had 30 gears intricately
designed and expertly crafted the gears
drove dials and hands on the front and
back of the device despite all this
information they still didn't know
precisely what it did while the world
waited for more information on this
mysterious device that open the door to
a lot of theories I love theories I know
you do one Theory said the device was a
piece of technology taken from Atlantis
no culture on Earth at the time had this
level of Technology if the mechanism was
something powerful or important it would
make sense that atlantan survivors would
want to keep it safe I have to hide it
from the lorans
right some people believe the mechanism
was so Advanced it was proof of a
Creator like scaffolding left around a
building after construction was
completed another theory was that it was
left behind by aliens either
accidentally or as a gift alien
technology would explain how it ended up
in the 1st Century BC but the most
alarming opinion was that the anti
mechan ISM was a doomsday device a
weapon to depopulate the earth created
by an ancient race of reptilians lizard
people yeah maybe it was a clock used to
calculate a time when the weapon would
be deployed well isard people are very
punctual despite all this evidence one
of the most prevalent theories was that
the whole thing was a hoax some people
said it was nothing more than a single
brass gear and the scientists were
making up the rest what we do know for
sure is the antia mechanism isn't going
anywhere where even though it's been 123
years since it was pulled out of the
ocean we're still uncovering more of its
Secrets all the time eventually we will
know everything there is to know about
this fascinating device and maybe even
design our own but even if we can build
one the question is should
[Music]
we in the Ching haai province of China
on the southern shore of tws lake is a
pyramid-shaped mountain called Mount
bang in 1996 archaeologist bwu was
exploring a cave inside mount bong when
he made an unexplainable and
controversial Discovery inside the cave
you found iron scraps all over the dirt
floor who found iron scraps you found I
found you found me you so
confused along with the iron scraps
there were oddly shaped Stones standing
on end but most most mysterious of all
there were iron pipes running deep into
the mountain and here the story takes a
turn because the cave wasn't naturally
formed it was a triangular-shaped
entrance carved by somebody and mount
bong wasn't a mountain it was a pyramid
also constructed by somebody the more
scientists looked at Mount bong the more
questions they had none of this made
sense this is the middle of nowhere
nobody lives there and as far as anyone
knew nobody ever had and those iron
pipes according to the Beijing Institute
of geology the pipes were forged more
than
150,000 years ago the pipes vary in size
from 18 in in diameter to as thin as a
grain of rice and later Expeditions
found Pipes big enough to walk through
and there were humans living all over
the world at that time but Metallurgy
wasn't discovered until about 10,000 BC
so who created the pipes and why while
there is no clear purpose for the pipes
more more are found at Lake tosu 260 ft
away along with more strange Stones the
pipes at the lake are both above and
below the water level some researchers
believe the pipes were used to pump
water into the pyramid possibly for
cooling purposes considering twso is a
Salt Lake one Theory suggests the pipes
may have been used for a process called
electrolysis when you pass an electric
current through water the water
molecules separate into oxygen and
hydrogen atoms saltwater is a better
conductor than fresh water the salt
helps separate the oxygen and hydrogen
more efficiently and hydrogen could be
used for a lot of things like refining
oil treating metals and processing foods
but hydrogen could also be used as fuel
in addition to dating the pipes the
Beijing Institute of geology tested the
pipe's composition they're made up of
30% rusted iron they also contain large
amounts of silicon dioxide which is
commonly found in quartz as well as
calcium oxide also known as quick lime
these are interesting materials iron
conducts heat and electricity and when
quartz is subjected to stress like
millions of gallons of water flowing
through a pipe it generates electricity
this is called the pzo electric effect
remember the Great Pyramid in Egypt is
also built near a water source well
technically it's on top of one there's a
large aquifer under the Giza Plateau
also there are chambers within the Great
Pyramid made of quartz and metal pipes
have been discovered within the pyramid
complex ncol Tesla built his famous
Warden Cliff Tower using these same
principles using this ancient method
Tesla believed he could generate free
unlimited energy that could be beamed
wirelessly to any place on Earth the
Illuminati would never allow that they
didn't when Tesla was close to a
discovery his investors pulled their
funding and invested in oil instead War
Cliff Tower was eventually abandoned now
if you're interested in specifically how
this works and what happened to Tesla's
Tower I've linked to another episode
below now calcium oxide or quick lime
found in the pipes is also interesting
quick lime is highly volatile and
chemically reactive if you expose quick
lime to water it causes an exothermic
reaction in other words it generates
Heat lots of heat one liter of water
combined with about 7 lb of quick lime
generates about 3 and 1 12 megga of
energy that's basically a gallon of
[Applause]
gas and if you remove the water quick
line reverts back to its original state
and as long as you have a stable water
source like a lake you could repeat this
process over and over again now besides
these common materials the pipes also
contain 8% of the material that could
not be identified but here's a thought
we've got iron pipes that can carry
water or some other medium electricity
to convert water into oxygen and
hydrogen we've got quick lime which when
exposed to water creates heat the heat
causes the hydrogen to expand the
expansion of the quartz within the pipes
generates even more electricity and this
process can repeat over and over again
all happening inside a pyramid well
that's the same process used to make the
Great Pyramid of Giza a power plant all
built 150,000 years ago I know what that
sounds like to
me in the 9th century on a grassy field
somewhere in northern England Nordic
Viking squares off against a Saxon house
Carl before kns the house Carl was the
highly trained Elite Warrior of medieval
Europe against the Viking this Warrior
should have the advantage the Saxon
wears chain mail armor while the Viking
wears only leather the Saxon has a
shield light and strong the Viking has
no shield and the Saxon sword is larger
and stronger than the Vikings the Saxon
Warrior is confident he charges forward
and takes a few heavy swings the Viking
defends with his short sword the Saxon
steps back confused he's fought Vikings
before usually their short blunt weapons
shatter when hit with heavy English
steel but this Viking has a magic sword
at least it appears to be magic to this
9th century Saxon being lighter and
faster the Viking sidesteps then lunges
forward he thrusts his razor sharp blade
through the saxon's chain mail his armor
should have easily protected him from
this attack but the Viking sword pierces
the chain mail like it's not even there
the Saxon falls to his knees as the
Viking withdraws his sword the Saxon
more confused than frightened sees
writing on the side of the blade a name
it's a name he's heard before and in
that moment everything makes sense then
the world goes
black this blade and others like it were
virtually indestructible and unbeatable
in battle they weren't elaborate swords
gilded with gold or Jewels they were
pretty ordinary looking but they were
easy to identify as they all all shared
the same inscription ulbert created
using a process that would remain
unknown for centuries the ulbert was a
revolutionary high-tech tool there were
only 170 of these swords left in
existence all forg sometime between 800
and 1,000 ad though ulbert swords are
usually associated with Vikings it's
actually a word of Frankish origin it
was most likely the name of the
swordsmith who created the blades now
the process of making a sword in the
11th century wasn't an easy one one in
order for iron to be used as a weapon it
had to be forged into steel so iron was
mined and smelted in a furnace with
charcoal which is mostly carbon iron
itself is too soft to be used as a sword
the blade would bend and Chip and lose
its Edge too quickly to be useful the
carbon hardens the iron so it keeps its
shape and sharp edge for longer but add
too much carbon the metal becomes
brittle it took a skilled and talented
Smith to get the mixture just right now
once hot enough the iron forms a gooey
spongy Mass called a bloom and after the
bloom is removed from the heat it's
hammered over and over again to remove
impurities known as slag slag is
typically Trace Amounts of silicon
manganese sulfur and other elements
blacksmiths would heat and Hammer the
metal over and over again to separate as
much slag from the iron as possible and
because of the limited technology of the
time the impurity of the steel was still
pretty high and the amount of carbon
they were able to get into the metal was
pretty low even the best medieval steel
is primitive to even the lowest Quality
Steel that we produce today except for
ulbert
steel experts have said that an ulbert
sword would have been like a lightsaber
in medieval Europe and that's not that
much of an exaggeration ulbert swords
were centuries ahead of the competition
they were Superior to all others in
sharpness in strength flexibility aler
steel was also very lightweight this was
a huge and unfair advantage in combat
the sword could withstand an enemy's
blow without breaking a common fear
among Warriors in a time when Fighters
wore coats of chain mail an ulber sword
could cut through this defense more
effectively than other swords modern
scientists have examined ulbert blades
to try to find out what made them so
special now first they found that almost
all impurities were removed from the
steel uler blades also had a carbon
content three times higher than other
swords from the same period now here's
the thing to achieve this level of
Purity and the carbon content of the
ulbert sword the metal would have need
to have been liquefied this causes
carbon to dissolve into the iron forming
an
alloy the high temperature also removes
impurities more effectively a
temperature of 2400 de f is needed for
this process the resulting alloy is
called Crucible steel because the metal
is melted in a large Crucible now for
hundreds of years Smiths tried to
duplicate olber steel but nobody could
come close Albert was a man a thousand
years ahead of his time and nobody knows
who he was
but many people still wonder what else
did he
[Music]
know physicist Francis parin sat at a
nuclear plant in the south of France
thinking to himself this cannot be
possible he was examining a dark piece
of uranium ore but what he discovered
didn't make sense this piece of uranium
had somehow undergone nuclear fision but
this uranium was mined nuclear fion
doesn't just happen in nature and even
more confusing this uranium ore was
almost 2 billion years old atoms are the
building blocks of all matter in the
universe the Sun the Earth the air we
breathe our bodies themselves everything
is made up of atoms but atoms can be
split and when that happens energy is
released and this energy can be
harnessed and used to charge your phone
or power an entire city
or
[Music]
splitting an atom is called nuclear fion
and it's a very delicate process to
start you'll need a high quality fuel
source like uranium or plutonium and
this is thankfully hard to find and even
if you do find it it has to be refined
before it can be used next you need pure
water like really pure as there no
chance of a nuclear reactor in here HH
none unless it works with vodka uh it
doesn't the water used for the fision
process in a nuclear power plant has to
have all minerals removed then it's
filtered and finally distilled if
there's even just a few contaminated
parts per million in the water Vision
won't happen naturally uranium contains
a very consistent and specific amount of
the isotope uranium 235 and when u235 is
split for a brief moment it absorbs a
new Neutron and is turned into
u236 then u236 is split into other
elements like barium Krypton or
strontium since all natural uranium
decays at the same rate any uranium
pulled out of the earth should have the
same exact amount of
u235 the only way literally the only way
for uranium ore to have a lower
percentage of u235 is through nuclear
fion so Francis perin was faced with
concrete evidence that nuclear fion had
not only occurred before it was disced
CED but it happened 1.8 billion years
before after further study perin and his
peers concluded the uranium Mo had to be
natural and vision somehow occurred
naturally but American chemist Glenn
seaborg didn't agree he said in order
for u235 to burn through fision the
conditions would have needed to be
exactly right they'd have to be perfect
Too Perfect for nature man-made nuclear
reactors are built with extreme
precision and no natural water Source
would even be close to Pure enough to
keep the reaction going for this to
happen on Earth 2 billion years ago was
impossible further investigation
revealed high concentrations of fision
byproducts within the mine indicating
nuclear chain reactions had definitely
taken place also the geology of the
region contained radioactive waste that
proved the controlled use of a nuclear
reactor that ran for 500,000 years at
the time the reactor was operating the
only life on Earth was single- celled
organisms
or out ofpl artifacts are sometimes
called oo parts and there are a lot of
them out there these were just a few of
my favorites but how many of these
objects are really out of
place now I love the legend of the drop
of stones but it's ultimately
disappointing the original story from
1962 is credited to writer Reinhardt
Wegman but no record of a writer by by
that name can be found same with the
archaeologist who discovered the stones
chupu and some Umi the professor who
studied them they don't exist either no
academic Works can be found for either
of them and their names aren't even
Chinese Wagner's photos of the dropa
discs are pretty low resolution you
can't see any details like the
hieroglyphics the stones supposedly had
it's more likely what he was taking a
picture of was a Jade B disc B discs are
elaborately decorated discs cut from
Jade and B discs are old they've been
dated as early as 3000 BC and maybe even
older but they were fairly common the
only mystery is we really don't know
what the discs were for they probably
have something to do with funerals
because they've been found in Graves of
important people and there's David
agon's book Exile of the sun Gods which
details an expedition into Tibet on that
expedition a race of people is
encountered who call themselves The
dropa the dropa claimed they were
descendants of extraterrestrials the
book tells the story of their UFO crash
their history and the artifacts they
left behind which included discs with
mysterious hieroglyphics such a great
story it is but it never happened oh no
in 1995 agamon whose real name is David
Gaiman sat for an interview with the
magazine the 4an times he admitted that
the story was all made up The Narrative
was edited by David agamon and included
a photograph of a curious disc-shaped
plate embossed with pictograms that seem
to be part of a record of the Journey of
the star beings from their home world
the author David Gaiman admitted to Ft
recently it had been written as satire
on the alien intervention in human
evolution genre still it is regarded in
some quarters as an authentic ancient
astronaut event he claimed it was his
greatest hoax and said his only regret
was that the book didn't sell better
there isn't a single person living or
dead that's been confirmed to have seen
a dropa stone so I think this one is a
hoax oh now the anti mechanism is not a
hoax oh that is a real object and it was
found on an ancient Roman shipwreck it
really was on that ship 2,000 years ago
all of that is true but despite all the
wild theories surrounding the device the
truth is actually anticlimactic and
comes down to a simple
misunderstanding many people assume and
many journalists State the antier
mechanism is the only device of its kind
and that it was created with technology
far beyond what existed at the time well
that's not true devices like this one
are well documented in ancient writings
and were known about long before it was
found in 1900 what made the antia
mechanism special was that it survived
it's the only known artifact of one of
these devices in
existence another misconception is that
we don't know what it does but we
actually do well how do we know well it
has labels on it
oh small colored stones show the
position and motions of the planets the
sun and moon were shown relative to the
constellations of the zodiac it
predicted solar and lunar eclipses and
what color the eclipses would be it had
a 365-day solar calendar and a lunar
calendar 19 years long a small colored
Stone rotated to show the phases of the
moon there was even a dial showing a
countdown to the next Olympic Games so
it probably wasn't created by aliens uh
well maybe aliens are big sports fans
maybe but aliens probably follow Sports
using equipment more advanced than
something May from Gears plus the device
has been recreated using X-ray and gamma
ray Imaging turns out the thing wasn't
all that accurate so the antia device is
real and a fascinating piece of
engineering but it isn't an out-of-place
artifact next the mount Bon pyramid
probably isn't a pyramid in fact the
word bong just means Hill in the local
dialect ah this is getting depressing
while the caves may appear man-made they
probably aren't the Triangular shape of
the entrance only looks that way from a
certain angle and there's no indication
of two collapsed entrances or anything
artificially created the pipes though
they can't really be
explained they really do appear to be
forged metal pipes they're really made
of rusted iron quartz and quick lime
that's all true and the archaeologist
who discovered them by you is a real
person who's real you is I is no you is
me is you that's what I said look I I
don't want to do again who doesn't me
you stop
it the mainstream theory is that the
bong pipes are just tree roots tree
roots yep tree roots can turn to Stone
through a process known as per
mineralization which is a type of
fossilization this happens over a long
period often taking thousands to
millions of years now this Theory sounds
plausible but the only source for the
claim is an article by Ginman weekly
from 2003 the article was originally in
Chinese but the English translation says
they found fossilized plant matter
inside the tubes this could be proof
that the pipes are in fact tree roots or
indicate at some point in the last
150,000 years algae or Moss grew inside
the pipes it's still a
mystery now on the surface the ulbert
swords defy science metal of such high
quality didn't exist at the time except
it did it was rare but it did exist
you've probably heard of Damascus steel
Damascus steel is one of the most
legendary Steels ever made it's
extremely durable and contains almost no
impurities the traditional method of
producing Damascus steel has actually
been lost to history but experts believe
the process involves layering Iron and
steel or multiple types of Steel the
metals are then forged together by
repeated folding and Welding this
process may be repeated many times to
create hundreds or even thousands of
layers this is what creates the unique
patterns that Damascus steel is known
for Damascus steel was of quality equal
to and probably even better than the elf
bird swords and Damascus blades were
around a thousand years earlier they
just didn't become widely known until
many years later but nobody in Europe
was producing steel like this until
ulbert Albert's swords were extremely
rare and extremely expensive an average
Soldier wouldn't have used one of these
and probably never even saw one they
were so expensive not just because of
their quality they were forged with raw
materials not found in Europe most
likely steel ingots from Asia were
brought by Merchants to the reinland
which is now Germany after being forged
in the reinland they're most likely Shi
North to
Scandinavia many still believe such
Advanced blades would have been
impossible to create with medieval
technology but modern blacksmiths have
been able to replicate the process it's
not easy to do but it is possible oluler
was during his time one of the most
talented weapons makers in the world
though nobody knows who he is a thousand
years later people people still know his
name the oo reactor Legend is partly
true and partly false first chemist
Glenn seaborg never said it had to be
man-made he did say for it to be
naturally occurring the conditions would
have to be perfect people then took that
as a claim and ran with it in order for
a chain reaction to occur the amount of
u235 would need to be at critical mass
around 3 to 5% now the current amount
found in natural uranium is
0.7% this isn't enough for fision to
occur
but 1.8 billion years ago the percentage
of u235 would have been much higher
enough to start a nuclear Chain Reaction
the likelihood of water being pure
enough is slim but not impossible
there's chemical evidence that a nuclear
reaction did occur most articles and
videos about the Olo reactor describe it
as a nuclear explosion like an atomic
bomb but that's not what happened the
uranium did undergo natural fion but it
was a slow burn that happened over
500,000 years that's not as dramatic as
a mushroom Cloud but it's pretty close
to how modern nuclear reactors work and
that brings up an interesting point in
the distant future all evidence of the
human race will be completely gone if a
cataclysm wiped out the human race
tomorrow it would take just a few years
for nature to reclaim urban areas in a
few thousand years all cities are buried
in 100,000 years all human remains are
fossilized in a million years all
evidence of the human race will have
mineralized even styrofoam and plastic
turns to Stone and crumbles in 10
million years all that stone the fossils
and every bit of evidence of the entire
human race is recycled back into the
Earth's mantle an archaeologist far in
the future would never know we even
existed unless he finds and tests
uranium evidence of our nuclear
technology would still be detectable in
uranium that future archaeologist will
be confused because even though there's
no evidence of civilization or
technology the uranium he finds will
show evidence of vision other scientists
will come up with theories about nuclear
reactors that spontaneously appear in
nature under perfect conditions but the
archaeologist feels there's more to the
story he has a nagging sense that
millions of years ago someone was here
and who's to say that this hasn't
already happened and that future
archaeologist is
us thank you so much for hanging out
with us today my name is AJ there's
Heckle fish
this has been the wi files if you had
fun or learned anything do him a favor
subscribe comment like share that stuff
really helps the channel and like every
topic we cover here on the wi files
today's was recommended by you so if
there's a story you'd like to see or
learn more about go to the Wi files.com
tips and if like me you're sad at the
end of every episode check out the wi
files Discord it's free to join there's
thousands of people on there and 247
there's somebody talking about something
weird and something fun and special
thanks to our patrons who make the
channel possible every episode is
dedicated to you and I can't thank you
enough for your generosity now if you'd
like to support the channel consider
becoming a member on patreon for as
little as $3 a month you keep the
channel going you get access to videos
early without commercials Early Access
to fun products like the Heckle fish
talking plushy and two extra live
streams a week just for you another
great way to support the channel is grab
something from the wifi store go grab
yourself a heck fish t-shirt and stick
your fist in one of these fist mugs or
get one of these Heckle fish tug and
fish animal fish
that's going to do it until next time be
safe be kind and know that you are
[Music]
appreciated
oh
yeah I play Bia and Area 51 a secret
code inside the Bible said I was
I love my UFOs and paranormal fun as
well as music so singing the like
[Music]
AA but then another conspiracy theory
becomes the truth my
friends and it never
ends no it never
[Music]
ends I feel the crap cat I got stuck
inside M's hole with MK truck I feel an
only true
away did Stanley cubrick fake the moon
landing alone on a film set with the
shadow people
there through R well aliens just fought
the smiling man I'm
told and his name was cold and I can't
believe I'm dancing with the
fish fish On th night
wedn the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the truth so
the all through the
[Music]
night
the MTH man Sid and the solar Stone
still come to have got the the secret
City
Underground mysterious number stations
planets Areo to project State and where
the dark Watchers
found a simulation don't
you the black knack a l it told me so I
can't believe I'm dancing with the fish
he fish on thday night they J
and through the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the truth so
the all through the
night fish on Thursday night WN they J
you and my me all through the
night all I ever want want to the truth
so the bat all through
the good love to Dan good love to Dan
good love to Dan good dance good loves
to
dance good to dance on the dance ball
because she is a camel and camels love
to dance when the feeling is right on W
in
[Music]
time